welcome to the iron Lord podcast episode
number 20 and I'm very excited about our
special guest this week so we're gonna
get right into it I've been following
this launch journey on Twitter and
YouTube for some time
he's one of the most entertaining
personality in these gaming streets but
always keeps it real to his fan base and
it's never afraid to challenge his own
personal viewpoints as a multi-platform
game besides gaming you also give you
his opinions on popular television
movies and weightlifting with his
hilarious slash sometimes co-host Lord
Chuck introducing the host of the solid
cast podcast the men demands
uncompromised 60 frames per second and
dead zone free controllers and the main
reference to your girlfriend where she
questions your manhood about playing
video love it
Lord Rev is in the building how we doing
sir what's up thanks for having me on
very impressed I like that I like that
in trollman cuz I've got a better much
love much appreciate a glad to have you
when are you on the show for a little
bit in the realm of the Lords so that's
always good and of course we have the
usual suspects at the round table my
brother from another mother the co-host
with the cold most Lord addict are we
going sir
pretty good I just want to say some
anchor man shut up he's on Twitter
coming at me right now I was like
where's this one o'clock premium
experience you guys read unprofessional
he's exact he's excited dude L and of
course we have the gaming so Louis the
Lord who loves the single-player
experience no longer Illuminati my man
Lord sovereign are we doing sir doing
good man just for recovering from love
15 hour days this week and next week
says them be tough but uh I'm running on
fumes I'm running on fumes a lot of us
but it all feels a lot addict to them
and we all hurt a little bit
my heel and of course the excess gamer
oh the Lord who demands nothing more
than the premium experience Bobby Lord
King how are we doing sir
oh man I'm doing great it was back is it
good to be back uh last week was a
really long show but it was a great show
so hopefully we can emulate that and you
know give that great content again this
week absolutely absolutely of course it
is low [ __ ] NATO here giving you that
gaming realness so it's gonna go real
quick into what everybody's been going
start with Lord Rev what what have you
been playing I heard some some pub G
going on some battlegrounds what L
saying we've been playing a long as your
catalog mm oh I gotta tell you man
player knows it's really all I've been
playing lately it's gotten so much to
play I actually know what I was playing
evil within the other day
mm the game yeah excellent and very
underrated game from what I understand
yeah oh you know you have those people
that they don't want to play it because
they play resume even when they think
they cheat actually feel that would have
been better than uh Resident Evil 7 no
no okay listen ah dude I hated that yeah
halfway through the game I cut it off I
saw them the thing is my um I didn't
play like how everybody else is playing
it so I have a caveat to my experience
with the game my experience with the
game is probably the best VR game that I
have to date so I'm playing in VR and mo
your space yeah yeah yeah this is the
most horrifying game that I have a red
anchorman wants to see a UH an
arm-wrestling contest can you keep it
[ __ ] is Michael yeah tell him an X III
you know we hook up and we will give a
live show for the families you know
so Lois solve what have you been playing
this week ah a little that I've been
able to play just touching now play more
arms mom go that crap again relax let
lord
enjoy his game but this is good just a
question knowing you said you said your
son was just running through everybody
was it like on the easiest no I just
turned it on and um I was playing it and
you had the curious face now how you
look at it like oh my god I got a new
game sauce I say here's the controllers
that showed him how to hold it and he
said while I was playing he doesn't like
the fact that I was doing strategy and I
was moving the controllers and stuff
like that so he said I'll just punch my
hands and he just punch in the air I
said that won't work here and he fooled
me because he got the controller it was
a punching going to people and I got up
and left and I came back and he was like
four people in Wow
I'll say this if you if you turn it up
to at least the four or five then you
really and you really have to like new
strategy because they're the worst like
you have to you have to like punch crabs
out of the air you have to move you got
a dodge you got you like positioning is
important so there's a lot to it but I
wish I had more like a story mode or
something like that just a regular like
I know right for $59 yes elated so much
but I hope to 99 K price-gouging and ten
toes but I got it hello so they do maybe
doesn't be the million you know you
still fight it voted with your dog and
you know what I voted with my dollar too
because I can say whatever I want to say
oppor
the truth yak me as what I can run I can
run them through the dirt it doesn't
matter cuz I pay for citizen that
they'll then Lord addict what have you
been playing sure ex-con to a lot sure
he's been on earth lazy even blazer
little doubt in lower King what's been
on the rotation besides arms with your
son well uh yeah so that in there I had
to do that game yet oh you made me choke
but then I thought I will get back to my
stack right as I have a stack of
PlayStation
and I would love to get him to like zero
rising dawn and I'm not I don't
understand why I can't get into the game
like I got into it with Zelda no it's
for some reason it's somewhere barriers
in my Sony hate I don't know what I
really I'm sitting there and it's like a
good movie that you want to finish but
you keep falling asleep in it
oh okay that's interesting there's a
challenge in touch because I mean art is
off the chain I mean I mean I'm trying
to get that off which I wanted to click
and now I'm gonna finish it but it's not
it's not clicking it wasn't mine to it
like will you get around to it no doubt
I mean me I've been what I've been doing
the same thing pretty much Lord Alex
Donovan ah it's been definitely a lot of
XCOM I've been prepping ever since we
was at the PC gaming show we saw the
expansion released super hype for it so
I actually started the DLC flex going to
I've had a lot of fun with that mess
around switch a little bit of touch arms
a little bit I didn't really get too too
too deep with it but yeah that's been
pretty much it as far as me as far as
the gaming stuff so when are we gonna
get this thing going we got a lot to
discuss and dumb I want to jump right
into controversial topic that's been
going on in these streets right now and
obviously since the release of the Xbox
one X hate that name we call it Scorpio
but uh you know there's been a lot of
reports coming out now good friends at
digital foundry we're kind of like some
of the first two when I believe when
anthem was announced to talk about you
know it's using 4k checkerboarding and
we know the term checkerboarding before
we no stranger to it with the ps4 Pro
we've heard it introduce it so um I just
wanted to bring this to the Lord's
attention as far as checkerboard
rendering as far as scorpio games being
30 frames per second how do you feel
about it you know do we feel a way about
it and i want to start off my man lord
red first I'm very curious to get his
perspective on this so Lord Rev the
world of the checkerboard talked to me
how do you feel about all this on scope
hmm well first of all I don't have a 4k
TV so you're probably thinking okay well
your opinion on this isn't relevant
given on most of the people out there
you only made one 15% people have 4k TV
or 10% I don't know the numbers but uh
the checkerboard I guess is really not
that big of a deal in the grand scheme
of things but it is kind of shitty when
they boast most powerful console and
little pool and it's doing the exact
same thing the pro is doing in the pro
came out a year before you know what I
mean so it's like yeah but from a
performance standpoint it's like you
know I I wanted more options I wanted an
option between 60 and 30 I wanted that
to be a primary focus it's not I think
we all kind of knew it wasn't going to
be but I was hopeful you know what I
mean it was I had this hope inside for
some reason or other that maybe you know
Microsoft is a computer company maybe
they will make it an option they didn't
so that's the biggest thing for me
checkerboard I wanted to noticed anyway
so I'm playing on a 1080p television
mm-hmm we get super sampling yeah yeah
yeah it works primarily for 1080p
televisions and you're going to see a
little bit more detail because you know
that actually you know zooms it out and
shrinks it down to the television to fit
um okay I'm I'm with you in the same
boat as far as a 1080p 60 frames per
second because I always thought that was
supposed to be our Holy Grail and it
seems like that leap frogging in it
check in you know checker board and
trying to get with Sony is a
unattainable unrealistic goal right now
I know the realistic goal is 1080p
everybody has one of those televisions
right about now I think of what is it
there's ninety percent no can do 1080p
all right yeah seven 20s out there run
around I got a cheap on sale Black
Friday
haha you got those guys out there but 60
frames per second should have been the
goal it should always be the goal and
you know if you achieve a fork a
checkerboard us that's cool you know
some people don't know the difference
between native or checkerboard
I can't tell myself
oh um and I'm gonna be a hypocrite here
because I was teasing Sony when it was
like checkerboard much it's not real
and then Microsoft is like yeah they can
do it however they want and it's coming
to find out that most of the games
aren't native it's more games that will
then the PlayStation Pro will be native
4k but again they're also using
techniques yeah okay we all know that
you got to use techniques you got to be
realistic with it but again I'm a
hypocrite um I was saying that uh when
Sony was doing it as a problem Microsoft
was no it's cool oh that's an added that
check check is it answer you're sad
though you got hurt it's not about for
Katy Moore's about six K or get it all
know that this is just that I know the
system's not out so we don't know if the
game's release and they do have sliders
for a 1080p 60 frames per second or 4k
30 frames per second and Sony learned
during that period of time that they
needed to have sliders in a date they
were stumbling through so this is what
happens when you lead when you lead you
stumble you make mistakes and then the
guy that comes behind you is able to use
all your perfections that you use and
enhance that and don't make the same
mistakes you make so I'm pretty sure
Microsoft will have sliders as well I'm
pretty sure that they will have an
enhanced mode with 1080p 60 frames per
second or some games some games where
it's competitive games you won't be able
to do that because you have to be
competitive across the board so 60
friends versus 30 frames they're not
gonna do that the game will be rendered
at 30 frames per second to keep it
competitive but I think in a single
player experience they're maximizing to
the point that 1080p 60 frames will be
there in some games now let me ask let
me ask you to this on in reference to
that that whole thing like especially we
have like oh we will we more and I know
Lori attic we've talked about this
before too but I want to banish the rep
like would we be more happy if instead
of the 4k push that they say okay we
give us that 1080 60 option you know for
people like yourself revenue who not
really you know for oh I don't have a 4k
TV right now
and there's a lot of the population that
represents the majority that doesn't
have that so would you be more akin to
that right
or where you act with that farsta tell
me 260 yeah absolutely
Dutch that's like not even a question
man absolute ñå TP 60 over 4k all day
but do I've represent the mass
population of gamers out there I don't
think I do yeah I think I think you're
casuals make up the most of the gamers
out there and I don't think they got a
clue what frames per second is my plays
per second is I've sat him down fired up
a PC game and I'm like okay this is 60
frames on this and he's like ah dude I
don't see what you're talking I don't
know I think they now can you not see
this mmm interesting to be a gamer I
don't think they know what frames are
but I think they know less what 4k is
like if you asked but he knows what
resolution is men everybody think of as
a day Mike hey everybody knows what a 4k
TV is I feel I feel like it's not to the
standard we're casuals care about that
mm-hmm
I mean it's one of those things that I
hear both sides I think that people know
of it I mean some people might just not
be again like they just don't have
access or they're looking at it and
saying you know what this may not be the
greatest investment for me because I
don't know what the benefit is you know
I mean for the 4k aspect but I suppose I
want to get a loss on this you can look
right where is your whole feeling with a
first we'll start with you a
checkerboarding and then you know this
whole 30 frames per second with a lot of
you know sculptor towns that we hear in
announce Assassin's Creed I believe was
30
um crackdown is 30 which again and also
one last point when throwing for
everybody also is a lot of these we also
hearing on Microsoft first-party stuff
too because there's a there's a thing in
the in the streets now as far as you
know well the devs are not getting the
most out of this system and you know
created where we at with that as well so
lost I let me give you the floor right
now I'm actually I'm kind of two minds
about about this because I understand
why Microsoft went full tilt on the I'm
pushing 4k and true 4k I understand
because you had the message had to be
different than what PS Pro a PS pro was
talking about so obviously I get that
and again for me it's just the fact that
they they went and then they turn
checkerboarding into a taboo word when
it should have been was something that
should have been applauded it's not it's
something that honestly when you look at
it look at a console a console is
fundamentally different to a PC after
the Xbox one and after the ps4 the
thinking was by these my thinking was
that moving forward these consoles are
going to be more and more like pcs
especially in terms of construction so I
was thinking these guys are looking at
like a separate CPU and a seperate GPU
not putting everything on one chip I was
thinking this is the route that we're
taking obviously with Xbox one X they
put everything on one chip so they still
born that route so there's a lot of
engineering that goes into that so the
expectation and it's going to be able to
do the same thing that a get a PC with a
dedicated GPU and the CPU does is it's
unrealistic so them knowing that I get
the fact that there's a lot of great
engineering that went into the X and I
am and the fact that they can do it that
it can do what it does is fantastic but
they painted themselves into a corner by
turning checkerboarding into something
negative which it isn't and you know and
them knowing full well that all of their
games are not gonna be able to run
native 4k it just doesn't make any sense
because you never want to put you never
want to put your product in a position
where it's able to be scrutinized but
for for its negative points and and over
over being praised for its positive
points the moment you put yourself at
the very top at the very pinnacle of
everything that you do that falls below
that is going to get super scrutinized
so you change the conversation you see
the conversation should have always been
you know what we're going to shoot for
true 4k and 60 frames per second on our
titles but just know that just know that
that's the and make it very clear
because initially they didn't make it
clear now more and more when they have
conversations like yeah you know
developers can do what they want
developers can do this whatever works
for them whereas that should have been
that should have been narrative from the
very beginning coming from them but
nobody does exactly what you're saying
I'm
when the system is announced the hoopla
and the hype behind the system is so
fever pitch everybody's expecting the
greatest from every new system that Pro
they were saying the same thing zero
four eight crazy it's gonna do this and
then make way for it to get in your
hands like well not necessarily this is
the first time the system is not even in
your hands and they like whoa not
necessarily I'm like come on man
but this is this is a dingo see this is
what lik what Pro did Pro turn that
around and be like yeah we have dynamic
4k oh yeah but that Willie now is
another word that was and you found out
you had a turd in your hand after you
purchased the term you didn't get a
chance to have to you know a a turd on
the show oh I heard about that
checkerboard stuff you didn't get that
yet oh this is what I'm talking about
what Microsoft let them get let them put
the turd in your house first be happy
that you purchased that you know lady
Marie we're too much looking look at us
talking about it we're too much in the
know for that to be a reality
especially but we're gonna work we were
in the know before we got the pro drug
is still the narrative was like almost
policy that's the thing the chamber
boring thing wasn't an issue there was
no talk of checkerboarding anything
until the procas we had we nobody have
4k and it right just to hypocrisy that
comes with along with Microsoft and I
hate it too the fact that nothing dudes
rock let them get they day in a Sun at
the end of the day it's the most
powerful console and I don't care these
dudes got a sucker it's just that it's
the most powerful is the most powerful
checkerboard so let it go yeah but
there's no way and I'm gonna be there
line day one with you online I love you
don't worry okay my house you know we
are Oh
and again horizon Daryl doing looks
fantastic looks fantastic lot listen man
like a checkerboard me to death I don't
care here's the question that corner
right my question is do we feel though
because Microsoft has had their chest
out with the Xbox one X right and their
whole narrative is we are the true for K
Jean
is this false advertising duh because
okay now growl it wherever you haven't
been yeah absolutely is actually when
looking back to the Sony conference
whenever the hell it was when they did
the pro do you remember that with mark
Cerny talking yes
checkerboard rendering mmm-hmm didn't
they advertise checkerboard they didn't
say native 4k did that oh you know you
know you're so right they analyzed it
there and everybody was underwhelmed
they told you what the pro was from the
beginning that never look back at the
2016 III reveal of the Scorpio these
suckers made this this thing out to be a
monster your mom off oh well yeah now
it's doing what the pros do what it's
like yo what the hell again yeah so but
to to marks Ernie's a credit a discredit
he did say that but technically uh we
can triple the frames if we run it in
16-bit mode I said what the hell are you
talking about snake oil salesman a lot
of people in that conference and then he
showed me show some indie game that was
running at 60 frames a second 4k native
and had zero textures oh yeah like
Microsoft did minecraft oh oh why are
doing this it was that RC Pro Am looking
game that it was there was money later
okay 60 frames yeah commencing to
Microsoft's defense they are running the
guitar game at 4k 60p know what the
games are for money isn't arcs or K 60
is that like I think arc in super lucky
tails the only two times I know again
let me row here were lucky tails as
losing framerate if you look at no
problem video yeah I know Dez he's gonna
see this and he's probably gonna jump at
me later on for this statement but
making art 4k 60 what what accomplish is
that the game running at 30 does it run
well so like you know what we're gonna
do we're gonna run our 4k 60 but all
nationalities we're only giving you like
maybe 20 frames
archive person 4k on the Xbox 1x I think
arc is going 1080p60 with with high-res
textures yeah any clarification on that
because a lot of my video I watched you
think they're going 1080p listen can
only gain this a mainstream game is 4k
60 is Forza right it's got an
achievement within itself because you
don't have any title on the PlayStation
pro I could do that so I guess you know
Microsoft got really amped once they saw
that game running and it was high 4k you
got it a 60 he's again and we only we
got 20% more power left over he said you
won in only 80 put that out there put
that out this world you know our friend
Richard van hey oh let me give a shout
out to sage stage I told you that the
super lucky Tales was a same game just
an extension I want you to really
understand this I know this because I
have it I could talk about the stuff
that I have sir I returned my oculus
because I felt that it was trashed and I
know the company was going down sorry
oculus is true y'all have some things
some things we're left I purchased my
vibe I'm sorry I don't have faith in
your company it's rap real quick look in
the chat it go to chat and tells me to
as a Lord Ram if he's hyped for super
lucky tales may come on fix just what if
you're ready no that [ __ ] hey who's
that dude in the chat that said
checkerboard me to death real quick
before we move past this topic that
everyone's made great points on what
about the notion that people are saying
that a lot of these devs are lazy
they're not maximizing the power of the
scorpio and that this is kind of a rush
job and eventually you know I start
thinking about the pro to the great oh
I'm gonna give you a me give you uh the
whole skinny on that if anybody wants to
jump in first I'll give you the skinny
on it right after whoever goes first
anybody want to take to cite this uh
over I'll jump in I mean I think right
now like I'm torn about it because yes
we do know that the system is new
we do know that you know the death kicks
are just getting out and stuff like that
so I'm not trying to disrespect you know
the system completely and say that it's
not cable but at the same time where I
struggle with it is okay if you're gonna
say you know Ruby Soph is lazy you know
because it's 4 K 30 or whatever you know
the other times I renounce like for
example even Hampton you know when did
you foundry broke it down our friendly
Richard Ledbetter says it with the
vertical slice he said that yesterday
Scorpio were capable but there's great
checkerboarding techniques here and
there and obviously you know I was you
know me a lot anchorman we always go at
it with the Destiny killer that he likes
to tease me so of course I had to you
know what steady for me she came when I
went right to the jagged wood in the
whole stuff so I think my thing on it is
that ok yes they're learning it but if
the Microsoft first party games like
crackdown is not hitting it that to me
raises a flag like that there's also a
light on my hands to talk about the
single-player mode true but we've seen
crack now me and you we've been any
reasonable looking we be honest is that
when I stand my first exam is per second
though when he was playing it um it had
framerate issues rod it wasn't amazing
you're looking at the title itself now
if you're looking at the technical
aspects of set idle yes yeah technically
speaking it was a high-res crackdown one
oh sure I just breathed a look 30 frames
to be automated I'm still at 40 60 it
was 60 frames but it was dropping we
gotta get confirmation I'm pretty
serving it's necessary I know there's no
multiplayer they said oh my supposed to
there multiplayer is 30 frames per
second I know that for a fact
um but yeah the gameplay that we were
playing it was that in 60 frames per
second that's why it looks smooth and
then you did the explosions and look
choppy so I don't know yeah it's
probably getting a conflict also brings
it I gotta get cut cuz I'm pretty
certain that they said that it's a 4k 30
game and they Twitter went crazy to it
from here in a 60 yeah Laurel 60 King I
might hurt that 30 on that game
um you could attest it back and forth
you saw the the Forza right when you
played the Forza yes now when Forza was
going like when you do it a lot of turns
and it was cars in the turn
I saw dibs I don't care what anybody say
if you're 60 frames per second and it
drops down to frames you're gonna see
those dips because it loses that smooth
Butterfield
yeah it'll hinge okay right notice it's
very noticeable so I was looking at that
screen and then I stood back and I
watched the crackdown I said okay so I
see what he was doing the jumper when
there was nothing going on on the screen
and the screen was smooth the frame rate
was high maybe was the high 40s high 50s
but then I noticed yeah when you
actually got into the action of the game
but like he said it was a pre-alpha bill
that we was playing really you know when
I'm pretty sure it was on a computer - I
don't think it was on an Xbox one X so
those on 1080 1080 graphic cards and
video settings spoke to them I'm
actually a more more game stop right now
it's actually it's confirmed 4k 30 ok
for ya but it doesn't matter if this
game 4k 60 I still think it's gonna be
tarnished well polished but we're at the
point where we scrutinize everything
that Microsoft does and listen these are
the first development kits that are out
and your point was you know you hit the
nail on the head when you said you know
the XD X's that's when they're called
now instead of X decays or whatever um
they are in early development so these
guys are getting it they're learning the
tricks and we all know after like two
years into the cycle when the new
development kits are being manufactured
and pushed out to the developers and the
developers get a chance to get a hold of
that new harnessing of the power of how
the chip really works and how they can
share memory back and forth this is
really just straight off top they
freestyling right now so they see ya
they free so right now you're giving
them a patch right now because you're
feeling it's still early in development
they're still learning it yeah we give
everybody a pass like everybody gets the
pass but these dudes don't
pass this this and it that's where the
hypocrisy comes that's why I felt like
I'm in the minority like I'm swimming
waving my flag and I'm like yo come on
man give give us the same pass that
these dues I mistake we coming from you
oh okay so no soft yoga I've been
talking it's not about not giving them a
pass because we always going to give
them a pass with regardless the pro did
it you know and then pros and getting
better about it the problem is a date
they put themselves in this position by
claiming something and like they don't
give themselves any wiggle room ya
cooker come on man they gave us shirts
that says it's a monster it is a monster
it is a powerful machine but it's just
like you put your when you use certain
language and you keep pounding that into
and into the social consciousness
everybody's expecting that so when you
leave e8 from that then it only comes
off as negative if you don't say you
know if you're not touting 4k and 60 and
there's that all the time you're not
touting that when you do hit it people
like wow they hit it yeah the
conversation isn't money market and bro
and marking and always got to drive the
dollars we got a build up an
anticipation like what would be the
sense if you say yo we're doing what
they're doing don't ya weave out the
stuff like why they did it because they
needed to change what they needed to
change the narrative from what the pro
was saying absolutely but then again
they still they do good enough job to
tell me what number of dollars more yeah
yeah yeah rev Sargon no that's it I
agree with that dude they misled the
consumer completely and it's an Xbox
saying as a fan of Xbox I'm completely
and totally let down you know me how
long do we have to get crapped on by
Microsoft and still support their system
you know what I mean ever since they
connect they gave us a less powerful
system to shove a Kinect down our
throats you want me yeah it's like I'm
getting I'm getting tired Xbox man I
still like a more fully connected piece
of track dough Kinect is garbage here we
go I want it because I use it for my
youtube videos but if I happy are you oh
yes they will be useless
in your hand not the best part about
that connecting III do say if they would
have made it an option that she was able
to purchase like the first time there
would be no cells of the connect right
now you the see the end this is where I
say sir your fraud and a liar I'm taking
this one the reason why I say this
because 13 millions connect sold and I'm
under selling it because I think at the
end it ended somewhere like around 18
but 13 million connects sold in a
lifetime of the 360 think it's more than
that
y'all can check for me but you know that
it was able enviable I sell are the
problem they didn't support it after
that show all the 30 million had bought
it you couldn't expect them to be like
I'm gonna buy a separate Kinect for the
x1 oh I think that I think the mentality
of that was this they said well they
loved it so much if we put it in a box
it shows extra value but we can't do
that and still ship with the same power
let's under power our system just to get
it in it I mean I think that was a
conversation and without myself that's
why he's fired
oh I was a traitor we go we go in love
we go love but let let's wrap up a
little bit as far as that you know it's
concern you know I definitely hear you
know where I'm coming from o matic I
just want I just want to get you you're
a whole thing on that do you feel it was
all false our time you think Microsoft
put themselves in a position to switch
you to wrap this thing up look I've said
from the start for case trash I want to
innovate gameplay not resolution let's
move on okay and there we have it what
we call the bottle dibs lazy yeah and
yeah easy yes they are listen we all go
how many different platforms do they
gotta optimize for now
no many you know I didn't bring that up
elephants I did bring that up in another
podcast I said look like this gonna get
to the point where dad's wouldn't be
like this is too much work
it's like they have to do the three uh
the Xbox one the Xbox one X the pro mil
place the way station for not to make
in probably 16 17 different bills on PC
that they got to look for oh I don't
care about the PC but I mean I do I
don't um but excuse me aren't they both
fun Jaguars aren't the same CPUs being
used that a different um megahertz yes
so a slider isn't an order is it right
but and you know the PlayStation is
essentially the same box with different
memory shipped inside sorry is the truth
but to Laura's point like do we not have
any compassion for these devs who have
no apparent book d-flat yep yep I think
I think mostly the devs was pushed by
their publishers I think my gigs mulch
broken yeah that's nice but I say it's
like I was telling when people were you
know obviously uh people have been going
at Bungie a lot here lately a lot of the
Xbox people and I think that you know
that might be a Sony thing but I think
that you know I think it's a mixture
between that and I think they're just
being rushed out like people seem to
forget that like a lot of these
publishers pretty much had they hand
straight in the cookie jar when it comes
to these developers and they picking
what they want they're picking what they
want to do we've had we've seen multiple
cases of publishers ruining franchises
microsomal like EA talking nut like
about dead space you know we see
multiple scenarios of this I mean Bungie
was pretty much said yo if that [ __ ]
ain't out by this certain day I'm taking
your company okay they took they took
the stock options you talked about with
the destiny to release that is actually
accurate not for you I mean these this
is good subjects to talk about you know
and I definitely got some good feedback
from you guys
it's wait when everyone's at with this
whole checkerboarding and thing Laura
baby we can go on all day I don't
whatever would themselves what I want to
get into is man Lord addict you had a
little controversial topic that II want
to talk about anyone about the modding
community and what's been going on with
that so like what you get for the
roundtable so I just thought there's an
incident right now going on about
gta5 online when PC they have they've
stopped modding support on PC entirely
when it comes to GTA 5 and the PC
community's outrage they feel they
purchased this item and at the end is
you know they felt like they should be
able to adapt the code whatever however
they want you know do do these do their
single-player modding and they feel like
Rockstar shouldn't care about this but
Rockstar apparently those exact
different you know they've been very
vocal about you know they they don't
like the modding can it's not that they
don't like the mati community they don't
like it interfering with their
microtransactions online I do think
that's the real reason you know why why
go online grind and you know why even
put in money towards char cards when you
can go on single-player and get crazy
ass mods and never touch multiplayer so
I just wanted to ask you I wanted to
bring the question do you think that
devs should you know do you think they
should have the right to do something
like that obviously it's their
intellectual property but do you think
that they you know on a moral standpoint
that they should that they should do
stuff like this and do you think that
the gamers that support this game should
be outraged to something like this
happens oh it's going slow stuff what
you feel about it
I mean well from what I what I see like
they so they they allowed the open for
DES to be used again after shutting it
down so they they brought it back um so
honestly it's something it's a fine line
to walk because the modding community
has generally been the ones that kind of
allow the lifespan of a game to continue
especially on a PC front like these good
GTA before before GTA 5 was really a
singular experience like you go you go
in there and you play the game you play
the campaign and if you weren't if
you're playing on anything other than PC
that was it unless you're gonna go
waiting on single-player deal say
anything like that on PC you had the
opportunity people to mod the game and
do different you know funky things add
multiplayer mod stuff like that so it's
always been something as prevalent on PC
and it extends the life of the game so
now I can
to stand we're rock star coming from
where is with the model that they have
with GTA 5 and GTA online that makes
them a considerable amount of money
where they're constantly investing in
the game moving forward like you know
this is a game that's in the top selling
games every month and it's a five or six
year old game arm so they're making a
lot of money from it so obviously their
vested interest now is different than if
it was just a singular gameplay
experience that they put out five years
ago and just let it go so I get that I
get that but even so the modding
community um if you look at other games
if you look at Armour and what's
happened with Armour and it you know
player unknowns battlegrounds comes out
of that h1z1 through like you're a lot
of great innovation comes out of these
mods a lot of these people that create
these mods are should be employed by
these companies because they do amazing
things so I can get I get that they
don't want their initial vision
compromised with these mods but I think
it's a I think it's a necessary
extension of of their games and of their
product especially on the PC side and as
we've seen as even extending the
consoles with what would they allow it
with fallout on the consoles even though
it's limited in comparison to PC it's
something that's very important and
moving forward it's only going to expand
so they need to be willing to accept
that and that's it you know I'm again
this lines their lines and obviously
they have to protect their intellectual
property but it's something that has to
continue to exist period know though
Lord Rev where we at with modding in
this whole banning situation going on
right now PC gamers as a whole
or a bunch of crybabies absolutely took
away my mods no honestly I don't know
man I don't care i don't i don't use
mods I think mods are a gimmick I think
the trash I think the only good mods out
there are graphic mods all things like
all these mods that add crap I haven't
installed like normal I'd look on using
that mods for this room hop mods for
that game dude they're embarrassing
they're like embarrassing this is
horrible now is Rockstar being selfish
probably or did they give them back I
don't know dudes mods are just
completely and totally irrelevant to me
you know what I mean like the your boy
was just saying I'm sure there's a place
for him you know I don't care about mods
look little Revell Davi using mods 80
times no but like I said like you're
playing been playing puff gee a lot Club
G wouldn't exist without a mom dude pub
good the game is nothing but aggravation
for me good if it didn't exist them I
get that year back on my life that I'd
reckon the analogy is a negative
addiction is an addiction to you it's
not is that a gotta take online games
you get or cancer like like if they if
they did away with it all to get I'm not
the type of guy that to cry about stuff
like that like you think we're gonna
take this game away from you good take
it away
don't take this away good take it you're
not gonna ask me with your video games
if video games go away I'll find
something else to do or if you're have
you're not gonna be the first to make a
petition ever see my name on a petition
somebody lied love everybody would have
for that Lord King quick you had this as
far as the mod situation and possibly
being banned and GTA 5 catch fresh
sheets it's trash move on now I was
doing my best
Eddie hey respected um there's a place
you know there's a community loves it
actually it thrives uh for me I can care
less
um I think like Lord Reb says it's a PC
elitist crime we don't get it to do it
our way like shut up okay like if you
get a chance to do it like did they
mention in some of our console games you
know we have mods so whatever not one
time did I have a go over to download a
mod to enhance my game and I'm doing air
quotes enhanced my game
just by somebody termination that they
came up with in a basement and said
would it be good if everybody legs
glowed I don't care it's like it's
playing Fallout 4 wouldn't it be good if
we made like a flash bag you can run
really really fast you know I don't care
um but if it's something that's been a
staple in a community or in a in a fan
base then yeah when you remove something
that's been there like since day one of
course you're gonna have outrage because
that's your change in the norm people
don't like change right so you're gonna
be forced to either go back to it or
you're gonna have to dig in they gave up
apparently from what sovereign is saying
and they gave in so the point of mute
are obviously because they dig deeper
nothing I'll jump in if you're good king
no yeah like I may not fair which I say
and I feel the Lord to say I mean hey
I'm with revenue since that like I
honestly do not care about mods like
I've never really used them you know
it's not even when I believe fallout I
was like a selling point for fallout 4
right before an Xbox I guess it was the
first you don't want to bring Monsey and
I get it like this cool stuff you can do
and you know you can have Macho Man
Randy Savage running around fallout or
whatever it is good and I mean I mean
it's cool like don't get me wrong I get
it I understand it's just not my thing
it's not something I'm gonna you know
run out get a game because of but to
Lord addicts point you know in LA Kings
point I do see what you gotta say
because it's like you know if it's
something that existed before and now
you take it away you know there's gonna
be backlash like you know the community
is gonna feel away about that none of me
and so I mean again you know into los
Chavez point you know I didn't even
realize that you know that a lot of some
games were birth as a mod you know I
mean because of that so that creativity
that these guys come up with is pretty
amazing you know that they spend so much
time they able to do it you know
hopefully they can resolve it and just
real quick oh lordy what was the
reasoning behind them saying because I'm
still learning about the situation what
was the reason behind them banning like
what was rockstars whole thing like why
they doing this today
I don't think they had an initial like
out statement saying this is why I think
you know that they just threw a bunch of
PR statements down people's throats like
I said I do think it's our
microtransactions I think it's a shark
cards I do believe that's the true
intent behind because like I said you
play single-player mod where you can you
know do a lot more stuff why would
someone grind and you know buy char
cards on their multiplayer servers
because uh you know I was told that it
was single player that they disabled as
well so wow you know that meant that it
was some kind of reasoning behind that
they wouldn't go to a single player
experiencing and get rid of that you
can't even bring multiple people into a
single-player experience on their online
services so on I mean you know when it
comes to the whole service like I you
know mean the PC communities when I did
a few times on my channel you know I
actually made a video video once saying
that PC gamers are uh you know they cry
a lot that they have multiple criterias
that have to be met on their on their
service the platform for people who love
to cry on the you know it's an open
platform of multiple services
you don't bring something to steam it
you might as well just start a position
right then and there
gotcha so you know I I put it on this
you know I made a video and I got a lot
of bad feedback like the PC people came
at me with the intent to kill anything
it like Jesse that's why Center
crybabies absolutely all fair words are
but the PC there especially kind of be
doing it so I said it I said in the
videos like look you have so many
criterias that a game has to me because
I was talking about bad ports for PC and
maybe it's because of these criterias
you know if you don't put it on Steam
they they start rage and look at destiny
to look at you know games on windows why
isn't it on Steam people say they're
gonna boycott destiny too because it's
not on Steam ok so then you go that and
then you know you go to the mod support
if it doesn't have mod support I'm not
supporting it either
and it's like if it's not $60 you know I
understand the 61 I'm not supporting it
either like I have people that
loved it again you know they'll be like
oh I really want to [ __ ] with that all
hot might be from my language uh I
really want to mess with this game and
don't be like but I'm gonna wait for it
to be like $24 on the snow and steam two
or three years from now I'm like if
you're safe you're hi free and then you
know that they go on about you know the
the PC community's real big on to you
know the pre-orders which I do think
that you know consoles it's it's a lot
easier to preorder there's very few
consoles I actually have bad ports but
PC they get they get a lot of bad ports
so I would understand why they would
want not to preorder but what it comes
down to is just look like I feel like
you know the PC community they might be
the reason to why they don't get certain
ports to games like why certain devs
don't even mess with their call their
ports why you know Ubisoft has had
multiple dead ports because you know
it's like I said people wait for sales
they won't support them at a full price
you know if you don't do something to
the Conte ria of the PC community they
outraged at you you know I actually seen
a podcast once where they were saying
that piracy is okay because they want to
make sure games are functional before
they actually buy it that's it it just
it's it it just agree to be you know on
the only thing I will say just that like
like you say I mean if there was
something that exists and it's taken
away there's always gonna be backlash so
it's to be expected but you know we all
feel how we feel and for the most part I
don't think we're the biggest modding
guys but we understand why people feel
that way so shout out was blot Stratos
watch out this community so we are gonna
move on to the next topic I want to get
my main Lord King to the round table cuz
he's got a good one he's got we want to
talk about game focus consoles and I bet
you got a lot to say oh I got a theory
my theory is the reason why the Nintendo
switch software sullen at the rate that
is selling is because you can't do
anything else with the system much like
hey um it's not like you can pick it up
and you can divert your attention by
going to youtube there's plenty of times
sit on my xbox on my playstation I was
just being YouTube or Hulu or Netflix or
something else other than playing video
games the fact that the user interface
doesn't allow for that activity to
happen with the system anytime you pick
up your switch turn on your switch you
are primarily playing games so that you
know the numbers will be skewed in that
way uh the the software will be skewed
in that way Nintendo has made it like a
Darth of games so anytime any type of
good game comes out it's going to sell
in droves because that's three million
or four million or five million people
that purchase that switch are dying for
games so when you release a game if one
percent of your user base purchase that
game then you're fantastic and it
reflects this so I feel that if
Microsoft and Sony didn't have those
user interfaces that allow for such
things I know the marketing for both
systems or all three systems is
different Sony and Microsoft wants to
take that unused time they saw RIT and
said wow you know people are sitting on
the couch and they're using other
devices to look at Hulu Netflix and all
that and they use that that a whole
market employee as a Trojan horse if you
will to get these systems into your
living room 4k blu-ray oh I I don't even
have to buy a separate device no you
don't got that it's in the box you can
do that oh that's fantastic oh I can use
Hulu from here so it's two different
marketing strategies and I believe
Nintendo is dominating the games and
software charts just for the simple fact
you can do nothing else with play video
games with it hmm how do we feel about
that anyone was jumping I tend to agree
oh I think I tend to agree just because
it to fold like the fact that the system
is still fairly young in its life it's
only a few months old so people have
that excitement about it you know every
single week checking the the eShop to
see what's new I know I do
wit Jana Jana and I've been kind of
waiting off a little bit but not
definitely the first two months like
every single week over what was coming I
don't care if it's eight bucks or 20
bucks it's cool I'm gonna buy it
YUM but in terms of the marketing I
agree like where Xbox and Sony always
trying to take over that that that TV
time trying to take over your living
room you know where there's only admits
they're not they're trying to do the
same thing with all these extra apps um
where Nintendo I think the software is
selling great but I think they all they
need to take over that that spot where
they have those apps also because you to
me I would think that they want to be
that thing when you're you're on the
train where you're mobile somewhere
they're the only system that can do that
so they want to get it to the point
where you're pulling out your switch
instead of your phone to do this stuff
right right so again I think it would be
um be completely owned Artful they were
going to pull your phone out with your
switch
Oh Pancho don't get started on it it's
next our little boat go handle all that
hand
so I would think that at some point they
want to they want to create a situation
where you're pulling your switch out to
watch that stuff and not you don't know
oh but again you don't know what they
think it is an intent so we shall see I
realize I have Dinah get Lord revs
opinion of the detective spit show your
mother endless I remember I said you're
my life right walls were relevant don't
apply that by about 300 and that's where
the switch is on from this but what
about the red with off the kids got the
kids everything their little hearts
desire they have Kindles they got a Wii
that they never had which happened on a
main they didn't didn't ask for no
switch I say boy that's gotta say this
right quick and you know I don't want to
offend anybody but hum be this is me
being a hundred percent Cognito you know
me by now absolutely they say the
demographic for gamers most gamers
in their 30s right that is going on
that's what they say the fact that the
switch can have any kind of success
makes me very very sad you're not
feeling these bad children out in these
streets
you know if I'm in the doctor's office
and oh you know what let me let me game
I pull out my switch dude slap the [ __ ]
out of think of like you know solid reps
in there waiting for a doctor to you
know see it and you just see some random
stranger beside and Pilatus wait you
can't imagine what the dollar next Oh
give me one second I'm finishing up
Kirby over here a picture at the gym yo
hold on one more set I just got that
like in sets they were just passing a
switch that was it was it the marketing
Lloyd I was more doing young people
could stop more they put the switch to
play ball
they board to play 2k rebus Rev has
someone spotting him and he's like are
you gonna help me it's like man let me
finish this look all gone I got this
goblins over us so so needless to say
it's not on your radar hey hey I know
it's not but what about obviously we
know the tremendous success right you
know alas I'm not gonna get too much
into Lois armors
next time because I know we're gonna
talk MPD but we know it's a success do
we think that is just because like more
Kings point that is really not a lot of
games or so people are just so thirsty
that they just like you know what I'm
gonna buy anything and that's why
they're winning the software like dude
is that that question to me yeah that's
for you that for you as far as the
Nintendo's are they winning
yeah it's Rd and PE sales are concerned
outside of the like maybe the last two
months
I mean I guess sounds good that's
probably why
okay I do die I don't
[Music]
yeah no I understand your position a
baby flush the toilet move on I'm gonna
jump in I'll jump in my back I think
yeah this a good one King you have me
you have my gears grinding on this one
twisting the knife for me ain't no
switch gang so I'm part of the page
tribe but um yeah I think it's there's
there's some validity to what you say
because we do know that there's not a
lot of software around right obviously
no Zelda so like hotcakes
you know Mario Kart which is pretty much
uh you know we you ask the game as great
as it is you know I mean it's um you
know it's that so the software you know
me Lord Lord sovereign will buy those
little shop joints and um you know it'll
be one of those things that we're very
excited to see what the hardware can
push I know a game like fast or Amex
amazed me just the fact it was like you
know 1080 60 on a switch and it was like
an f0 wipeout slash cone
I was hype about it but um I guess yes
there is valid because validity what
you're saying the only counterpoint I
have to say anyway is that that install
base is still not in comparison to an
Xbox one or Playstation 4 so to me it's
still remarkable what they're able to
accomplish based on this low install
base by jumping on let you know I'm
going at the install base yeah and my
Gong is with you yeah with the install
base is I've personally never seen it
where a new system comes out and you've
got a system that's in the market for
like what is it three years now and
software wise worldwide
you know zelda is out beating you know
all these other titles arises and all
and all this other stuff and then you
know because the next month it's Mario
Kart which I believe Marek heart dropped
correctly from rolling soccer at the end
of the month it was like a hit
yeah it was like a three to four day NPD
technically uh-huh that they counted and
it's still one and the other thing is
one thing that Nintendo is not getting
knocked not I should say credit but
digital sales are not being counted yeah
and that's to me is a huge deal you know
because they actually had a sensation
well I know I know we don't go I know
y'all coming from you I know but the
whole thing is like digital sales is a
huge deal and I know a lot of people who
said when they got a switch you know
they don't get that big memory card you
know or you know how low the memory was
in it remember there's a big controversy
everyone's okay if you get a switch
you're gonna have to get you know a
memory card cuz you're gonna have to you
know download these games and yadda
yadda yadda and then the other aspect is
a lot of these games on digital some of
them are cheaper now they're starting to
conform a little bit because I believe
it was a the rhyme developer came out
remember and there was writing like it's
ten dollars more wise everything ten
dollars more on the switch that whole
bit so that's all my office pretty much
all I had to say on that I just feel it
that needs to be thrown in the equation
but I'm gonna let Lord King and Lord ad
it come let it go first I'll come right
behind up it go yeah let's go hear that
the cells are related there's not
there's not anything on this console to
play I've had this you know if it wasn't
for the huge success of Zelda
I think this that the install base would
be way lower than it is yeah you know
Mario cars definitely helped but you
know from someone who played it on the
Wii U you can explore kognito I almost
didn't pick it up at launch but it's
just like look what a Mongol play on it
it's so like I ended up picking that up
okay then you look at people like
anchorman playing snake past that game
wouldn't do [ __ ] on the switch if it
wasn't for nothing playing uh who was
the last time you heard someone say you
know what I want to play snake Pass look
you know they do have a lot of cool you
know genres on the switch but I do feel
like it being portable is one of the
reasons that you know some of these
games are selling I'm sorry Lord Cognito
how many times have you heard some say
they bought a game digitally on on
switch very few I've heard a lot a lot
that's done
no I'm not no because the switch came
out people were told that they had to
have a memory card that was what they
were told
cuz the normal were pointing at this bit
more but how low
memory was the only people I know that
spotted game digitally the people in
channel thought everyone else I know as
well stalk it now we're talking
semantics and I guess I answered all
that stuff so we can't really say until
we get far too fast you don't know the
whole community none of us will know and
we won't know they're not they're not
allowing him MPD is not tracking so need
an eye tracking Microsoft they're not at
this point they're not allowing their
dead digital sales numbers to be
included one under the BRE but I don't
want to get into a whole debate on that
but when it comes down to it like look
like I feel like features is just as
important as games you have to enervate
your system to be modern and to have you
know the Netflix the Hulu there's no
reason why switch doesn't have Netflix
like that makes no sense
but there's the reason and that's goes
into the topic the topic is I believe
that Nintendo is purple silly
manipulating the user interface to the
point that the only thing that you can
do is play games now is it your teaching
I believe so and there's no laughing
stock on the Internet
I don't think they're laughing stock
they're laughing all the way to the bank
BAM I feel look at it like you got a
system in this day and age it can't play
anything else but games even the three
BS to play YouTube so you never like you
exactly you've made this system that is
isolated within its crew ecosystem and
we're gonna give you this one game
that's gonna you know they're smart with
the Zelda they put out that one game
that's gonna take up hundreds and hours
of your time right okay
then they put a couple of games inside
the the digital store and they say you
know you're gonna play this it is a
reason why that game sold a one-on-one
and in some cases over once more than
the switch itself is the screen I have
to I have to get the success of the
switch to the Zota no other game that we
don't we're not discounting that yeah
well that's ultimately I feel like that
you know let's be real here
you know services like Netflix and Hulu
and stuff the only reason they were
successful was because of gaming systems
in places like you know
I remember one right Netflix was first
on xbox360 they brought it to the 360
first and you know you know there's
games like minecraft that came to
consoles that you know what you name
happen well I mean there but I feel like
you need features more a just as much
I've seen absolutely but let me ask you
this one question cuz a chat actually
cradles into chat made a good point
though you know he's saying like why do
you need Netflix if you're gonna play
games and the alter all the question I
want to ask you specifically Laurie
attic is remember when Xbox one drop and
the dawn came out Don Mattrick and he
started talking NFL and TV TV I saw one
of them Oh Lord Rev videos for the Xbox
one reveal hey babe
but there was a whole bunch of TV I
chose my words right but I said it's
just as it's it's on equal grounds as
games I didn't say games or levels or
legal ground that's right but Don
Mattrick made it seem like TV is way
more important on a gaming platform I'm
saying that you need features to back up
your games just as much uni games to
back up your features okay I use that
one uncle - nothing
are you okay what what about YouTube
what about Netflix like you guys need
content of the topic right if you if you
break the topic down to its basis form
Nintendo is taking a stance and they're
forcing a way of life on you and it's
being successful right are being
successful because of it one game that's
all it's not like they have right one
that game is in the wild now but other
games are selling at a monumental rate
even could offer even Bomberman sold I
said well I'm talking and like you know
a law Cognito
and he keeps bringing up the user base
numbers on the PlayStation and Microsoft
and their games are not selling at the
same rate as the switch and when I train
to him is I believe that is directly
related to the TV functionalities that
are built into these new systems that is
taken away like a gamer come out and I
say yeah I get that later I'm watching
this
[ __ ] we just dropped up what the hell
is pumping out on [ __ ] I got 30
episodes I just snap flicks to chill
jobs yes it did you get to the solid
reza situation and hold on this is leg
day oh he did some new stuff on you too
let me see how he did that
okay alright so okay I gotta incorporate
that in the nutrition oh and you get
down the rabbit hole we just talked
about that in YouTube and I'm doing this
on my system if they clock my time on
playing video games and clocked it on
YouTube and Netflix and Hulu they're
winning Netflix YouTube is always
winning off my system opposed to video
games
I'm sorry actually to to Lord of addicts
point imma let you jump resolve
glorified blaze made a point you said
that on if the switch got voice chat
YouTube and you know a couple more
third-party games that he's in so to
Lord addicts point you know he's saying
that if those features were there that
is important to him that he would
actually pick with her six million
people feel otherwise those clubs up in
the gaming install base is that really a
locked up 6 player place every year it's
not even now not years not out yet years
now he's right he's right here look at
what isn't a short amount of time what
they've been able to do is shut up
Microsoft I want you to yeah just
quickly just want to add like we're at
the point where Sony and expired
Microsoft don't really care what you're
doing on their system so long as your
system is on like that is the truth
about it they don't care if you're
gaming they don't care they want it on
yeah and they ain't Nintendo that's a
three right here they even have metrics
cuz if you remember when the Xbox one
drop you would get achievements for
watching YouTube it's like watching
Netflix and how many hours they're
tracking this stuff so I definitely I
definitely would you say about finish up
so definitely yeah that was this one
intended absolutely I mean again if it
meant like being able Netflix and Hulu
on my Nintendo being able to just lay in
bed and watch it and you know watch that
stuff if I don't have a TV in my room or
system in my room or whatnot yeah it
matters if it absolutely matters but I
think we're looking sucker
Minister you direct people to focus on
what your strong is that and and they
have no other leeway but to do you have
to do it so again and once they add that
stuff if they somehow are able to fix
this this whole chat stuff and we're not
your problem we're a product but enough
great lord got some going on this before
we move on and definitely with lot
Atticus a to I don't want to negate what
he's saying cuz he actually is a valid
points to but we are gonna move on to
the next topic and then we'll let Lois
solve Li dis we are since we have been
on the Nintendo switch topic the NPD has
been has come out and surprisingly
Nintendo did not win this month so I
want to get into acting shortages and
what's going on over there self what's
going on in these streets
so basically Nintendo the month that
they launched in March they clean house
and in April they did the same in terms
of console sales they want MPD hands
down now we get to May and they lose and
PlayStation once again wins MPD that's
because I Zoda affects wearing off now
let the bed the Lord finish the Zelda
does effect only of only it's only gonna
affect the people to have it already
like the Zelda fame you don't have if
you can have it it's not gonna thank you
know what I was referring to is people
that wanted to plays out or picked it up
and the rest you're sitting there like
why should I pick up a console they got
no peaches yeah good little free I think
the rest of thing I can't pick up a
console maybe there's no counselor to
pick up and I think that's what the
argument is idly honestly I think they
lost MPD because the unit went out there
last couple of weeks Lord Kylie don't
I've been talking about how if the
consoles are in the wild they're gonna
sell and they're gonna run through
everybody in terms of sales because it's
just it's the hot thing right now don't
think so hmm let let let there's a lot
of interaction are champing by two lords
one sleep
did you listen now they came out and
said that they apologize for the
shortages especially in the Japanese
market but it's gotten to the point
where like people they're trying to
bring in consoles that have already
already been shipped out to the states
back to Japan in order to fill me oh
that's how crazy has gotten to the
shortages so my thing is what is the
issue here
are they having issues with
manufacturing to a certain extent and
obviously that going to tell you that I
put it on me yeah yeah I mean or good
are they are they to a certain extent
also creating sort of an artificial
shortage in order to be ready to for all
these bundles that they have come in
they have a big splatoon push coming
with splatoon bundle um they obviously
going to want to sell you that headset
right um there were a few more consoles
in the wild when arms dropped although I
had no specific kind of arms uh you know
bundle or anything like that but they
were the consoles were a little more
prevalent in the wild that week that it
dropped and obviously they have more big
titles coming down the line for the rest
of the year they have Mario rabbits they
have Xenoblade Chronicles and obviously
marital Odyssey right they don't want to
sell bundle though you know I have
trouble believing them that it's just oh
we weren't ready for the amount of
popularity was gonna have I have a lot
of trouble believing that because
honestly uh you know after that first
couple of weeks that the system was in
the wild you knew that you needed to
have more stock market access yeah
thatthat I do want to say how long we
going to be before we can't take that
you know right the UH the install it's
still supplies used we're like four
months in how you still gonna say you
didn't know I want to jump any sobs
finish when you finish off those quickly
I mean I think uh the manufacturing
thing could be an issue because a lot of
the parts that go into the switch are
general parts that a lot of other
manufacturers use and probably use at a
greater capacity that they do they need
more of it so I can kind of see that
maybe it's difficult getting certain
parts for the system and maybe that
slowed things down um but honestly
honestly my my true feeling is that they
want
bundle these things up they know these
things are coming they don't want to be
short splatoon bundles they want to push
splatoon they don't want to be short
mario odyssey or zelda bundle over the
end of the year and then another thing
is that they want to make sure they have
plenty of systems out when their big
games out you know it's a thing you
don't want a lot of systems out in the
wild and have shelf space taken up with
these systems on week when you have
indie games coming out other third party
stuff that isn't as popular they you
know could the system is going to move
then the system's gonna where you have
your games out all right so I've trouble
believing them in Africa after okay I'm
gonna jump in real quick because it's
actually a topic I've actually
researched and um my opinion on it is I
were to say you don't research any of
the topics but this time you know please
- not egg formula but uh that real talk
like I did with some research on it and
deal what I'm calling this is controlled
hustle yeah they know like like Lord
sovereign don't make no mistake they
know they don't want those things
sitting on yourself and they want these
things to push with a release because if
you remember when Mario Kart dropped all
of a sudden those switches were
available right around release time you
know you got a text from Gamestop or you
got that whatever the thing that in
their defense though the real is there
is a chip shortage there's a chip called
the ran chip and it's a memory chip and
what's happening is Apple is taking from
that stock because of the upcoming
iPhone eight so there is a reality that
that chip is just not available in
abundance but like you said loss Arvin
they have to know this they have to have
been preparing that okay you're one of
your competitors or another market
leader is also coming from that pool and
you have to allocate accordingly and you
have to plan accordingly now they've
been doing the whole air shipping stuff
to Japan and you know and all this other
stuff to try to compensate and I get it
but at the same time that I do believe
that yes there's a shortage but they're
also restocking very curiously at
I'm of their big lightning split two
arms you know very oh all that stuff
which that that's what that's what I
found out I like lots get it on this I
don't really say about this
I think Nintendo uh I think they're
still lost in the times a little bit I
think they do got games I like to play
but let's be real here like people say
well you know what what I mean do people
or you know people want to say that you
know why are you picking up a console
that you only play one game for like
look I picked up I'll pick up a ps4 just
for Kingdom Hearts I know solid red
don't like this but you know I'll pick
up a console for one game I will in a
heartbeat it's not even food and you
know I picked up why are you turning him
into the the testosterone gamer like he
only played the hardest of our game like
I've got a watch no rest channel under
that hard tough exterior he got a bruise
close game somewhere do you take you
secret in playing Blue's Clues is
resident alive into that comment hey
ray-ray and camera gross enough look no
Rev uh we get your feedback on this with
me with this whole fake monster hell
didn't want me to say man that's good
sounds good maybe uh the less
something's in the more valuable it
seems you know yeah okay maybe that is
what Nintendo is doing who I don't
understand and like we were talking
about before like the games there's such
a like there's no games on the system so
when a game comes out of course it's
gonna sell good you know what maybe
maybe these suckers here are doing
everything on purpose you know what I
mean on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one you
can go get countless games and like the
other guy was talking about with all the
apps the movies the Hulu's and all that
if so much more to do on the switch when
a game comes out
that's all there is to do on the system
so maybe all this is controlled in their
benefits mmm a clergyman said Nintendo
has been about this hustle since the
wish about this before them this has
always been their hustle and what what I
really don't like is their selling you
an inferior product I'm talking about
the software now I'm game into the
software if you're taking the software
you put it on multiple systems they are
always there in theory of product and
they selling it at a premium price $10
in the fun of dollars more than the the
better product which and I don't know
why we're standing for this which
funnies they chose that you know the
cartridge were and they're like you know
what we chose this option but you're
gonna pay for them because we don't want
to take more than we want you to put it
on the price of gaming utilize our bad
judgment yeah that's gotta true let's
get a cheap no but you always going to
subsidize their bad judgment and the
thing is though if going to rob that
they went with the switch being portable
you had they had no option but a
cartridge unless it was gonna be all
digital so can have yeah some can have a
CD bass you get a rebate close that is
not true like we we not the rich
initially station portable was the UM DS
Edition it was a it was a disk encased
in another plastic so that you wouldn't
get it around like it wasn't you and
these were not the best solution to but
I love propriety and also Sony tried to
get their hustle was with those memory
cards to remember they had they always
dancing with the memory cause but their
games was priced appropriately right hey
let's be real here the big the biggest
hustle of all is PC graphic arts
manufacture but don't don't let's not
even jump over this that's just think
yeah well we are we're not gonna get
derailed all for this because it is
Nintendo needs to be called out on the
carpet now now this I will say I will
say about the cartridges cartridges do
not cause what they used to cost either
it's pitch it's still considerably
cheaper than what it used to be you know
there yes yeah so the price gouging
still is in effect I mean it definitely
is shout out toward katsu
we had a spirited fury in Twitter
tweeting each other like wow of
woodpecker's um going back and forth and
he explained to me that he is picking up
a game called battle chasers which I
explained to you guys before which is a
fantastic game on other platforms um
other than the switch now he yells out
the portability of said game and I said
that's great you're missing my point my
point is you're gonna play 6495 for said
game I'm going to pay I don't know
probably ten to twenty dollars cheaper
for the game is going to be running in
either 4k checkerboard 60 frames per
second 1080p 60 frames per second but
it's going to be running at a higher
resolution on a opposite or opposing
system cheaper and Nintendo is forcing
you to buy this game at 30 frames per
second and charging you 10 to 20 dollars
more and I think that business practice
needs to be called out it needs to stop
some type of petition or something that
we can get celebrate design needs to go
up I mean it he's a reverend it will
will put Rev as the face of effort well
absolutely like he said of his
signatures there he didn't do it why I'm
saying that
why is gamers will we allow ourselves to
be beaten and dragged through the
streets by Nintendo just because they
don't have any games yeah I mean the
great thing guess so just the price
thing the price thing is fouled period I
mean for me though the argument I'm
making the same one that look about who
makes is that if that game sitting on my
xbox 1x probably doesn't get the play
that it gets on the switch I would get
it and it would sit there and I play
more you know Triple A games on that
system as opposed if I know I picking it
up on a switch I'm gonna play it through
and then at some point I'll probably
purchase it again on the Xbox one X or
whatever and
not to cut you I mean honestly that's
the same reason why I do it the reason
for me is like this games like let's
keep it real like rocket law rocket
League just got announced for them right
I really didn't play it I mean it was a
great game I played it a little bit but
I know that game is suited for me on the
go when I'm at work or I'm older I'm on
a train I'm saying like so there's
certain games that to me just scream
switch and portable and on the go as
opposed to me sitting I'm not buying
I saw the lawmaker man in the chat he's
going home right now I am not buying
snake pass lord anchorman it's sitting
in my house like that's not happening
like that I just know I'm on my Rev mode
I can't vision that but as far as if you
went if there was a shot of me even
playing that game it would have to be
downloaded securely on the go that's it
there's just certain things that you'll
pay the $20 more to put on the girl yeah
absolutely if it's something that I want
I'm paid it's my money I'm voting with
my dollar so my thing is if you don't
like it vote with your wallet and don't
support it that's my thing but we can we
can't get mad that they're hustling
people and people are still falling for
the hustle they still run it out they're
spending extra money for a nice little I
agree a hundred percent why change of
business practices when the way we don't
know don't if you can continue to gouge
the public because they're ignorant on
said matter yeah you know like we said
we all agree like even arrested like
this some bit of hustling with these
this fake demand I remember back in the
day with tickle-me-elmo and all that
stuff in your Christmas time kids watch
my new $100 on checking me almost
exactly but it's like you know when you
create fake hype but you make this
must-have item they think they've got it
down to a science
grandpa Nintendo has got it down to a
sign and until people vote whether while
it is gonna be the same most rugged days
but that's what I got real quick I know
he went ran too fast but um I just
wanted to I know lost rad he was in a
tent and he asked a question but I
wanted to bring this up real quick real
quick everybody from the Xbox one
Scorpio based one we know about right
now based on everything that's
are all of us in this party at the round
table buying one day one stop a riot
Oh Adam I'd like to say I'd like to say
I'm not gonna buy it but you know you
already know I'm going to don't you go
it though Lord addict I'm curious are
you buying it day one
uh day one a 2018 oh that that 2017
November what is it little cinema I
can't look here's the thing like I had
okay I got a PC I got an Xbox platform I
can't justify going out and spending
extra $500 even if I trade in my xbox
I'm still at least paying 250 to 3 if I
doing that when I don't even have a
Playstation platform II so there's now
there's nothing that could smile on it
like even uh like a wasn't shadow of war
or and nothing nah I'm still playing the
same game it's just gonna be slightly
it's gonna be slightly better okay so
for your thing is that resolution thing
that Forte means absolutely nothing to
you
not a damn thing gotcha okay I see what
you have well I'd rather play the
exclusives for PlayStation like the 15 I
have never touched then pay $500 to play
shadow horror game okay I think yeah I
think I'm in agreement with um Lord King
the wrestling yet it's a gay one bar for
me just for the simple fact I'm the type
that if there's better technology out I
gotta see what's going on
you know me Evan yeah yeah see I gotta
you know it's like we gonna put the TV
side-by-side go see who's dropping the
fire it's really really quite common
corporate absolutely absolutely oh yeah
shout out shout out the cradles we
definitely corporate slaving on that one
but oh yeah I mean Lord Lord servo is it
without any reservation sound it out
anyway it had it out and I can toggle
that one but I'm getting it a mom my
mantra is he who ends with the most toys
win so oh I'm sorry if you're not
getting it
I'm picking up tool and I'm gonna have
the spare something good
tell her mind I'm trying to tell you I'm
gonna tell you I'm picking up two in the
spirit of you I'm gonna go there I'm
gonna have a lord kognito hat on and a
lord of anchorman hat on I'm and when I
purchased I'm purchasing for the team
and when we enjoy it when I'm enjoying
it I'm enjoying it to you so don't worry
about it
that's what man Lord kick the excess
Gabriel I got these and miles there's no
way I can justify going upstairs and
change in my experience by going up sits
or regular Xbox one that shouldn't be
happening
Nara before we close up rapidly are you
in the process of gonna do the 4k thing
you're gonna make the 4k joke
TV as well oh no no no desire to go 4k
not for a while so we got 1080p super
sample that bad boy for a little bit
they're not fair enough but uh we're
gonna wrap this thing up and I'll
definitely want to shout out a little
salad for coming through man much
appreciated talking gaming at the
roundtable with us so where can they
find people find you ref what's going on
with you these youtube streets mmm
sala breath i appreciate you guys having
me there's good hosts kognito I'm
impressed I'm impressed with your
hosting skills I like that real smooth
thanks a lot we she ate you have been
wanted you on the show for a while and
I've always watched your content you
were i'ma tell you right now look king
you've got to watch some of his videos
with wifey and kids and his man Chuck
hilarious were like you have to watch
this man like that you would laugh you
know what lookin will get a kick out of
that video solid red put his Freddie the
in a what was a solid red it was like a
big ass burger at McDonalds on ponies
yeah that's about 16 patties yes
he's busy yo I think I've seen your
channel yeah I wanna yeah you know what
I probably I probably seen it I'm a
double check it today solid red is the
only dude on YouTube that when people
was like I don't want I don't watch
videos that don't have quality videos
he's like cold my beer
doesn't pleasure to get the man in here
we go wrap this thing up so of course
Lord addict what's been going on with
you industry's microphone you oh you
cannot catch me at gaming at it YouTube
you can catch me on Twitter at a gaming
addict IOP definitely tune into the
planet xbox podcast Tuesday well we're
giving away a $50 Xbox code pretty much
kits booze you know bribing people to
watch his podcast but that's besides
okay yeah watch this podcast when I bust
that but but I do want to thank uh Lord
sovereign for coming off not loving the
word read for coming on uh I know we
talked about a Nintendo and he seemed to
be fall asleep there but I appreciate
you uh pushing just discussed in his
voice when we talk to us but but shout
out the red because he played Zelda Wow
impressive
look I played four hours of it for our
Wow impress Lord sovereign we can the
fine people find you the five people can
find me on Xbox Live FBX sovereign PSN
be examined one word and on Twitter Lord
saw by OPA
and thanks to ref for coming on
definitely member with no problem
of course excess premium to Scorpio
gamer Oh Lord King my people fight I
like that you like that way you like
that too cold opieop yeah
Oh Instagram Twitter Facebook oh but see
player PSN now what I need is I need my
team you know to galvanize it in and
invite me on this PSM because I have
three friends on my list and that's
about it
oh oh is Xbox 360 lover
oh not fanboy at all not fan
wait for them slides maybe or yo stage
there's any time you can say corporate
slave confirmed it's that with peg
gamertag yeah yeah you know what listen
uh I'm an apologist for that system and
all I the only reason your your tag is
that is because you can't change it yeah
yeah that is kind of true Bob you know
I've never tried and I wouldn't if I
could
all right and this course is real or
Cognito we giving you that gaming
realness man appreciate y'all coming
through everybody love rap everybody and
like I said we saw the best podcast you
never heard so we're out here in iTunes
YouTube SoundCloud all the major
channels we appreciate the support we
got more stuff coming and on that note
we have hit peace